this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website hey guys it's max today
I am super excited to be bringing you
guys a comparison between the brand-new
2020 MacBook Air in the mid 2019 base
model MacBook Pro there has been an
excellent value macbook that we have
been highly recommending and we're gonna
figure out which one of these machines
is the best value for most people now
we're not only gonna be talking about
specs and performance for the CPU and
the graphics which are important we're
also going to look at things such as the
keyboard the speakers webcams
microphones displays we're gonna look at
video editing performance some gaming
and also we're gonna look at thermals
and I'll show you guys the insides of
these two machines we're gonna test how
hot they get and what is their
performance under loads so let's get
right into it
now as I stack these up I do want to say
that we have links to both of these down
in the video description below both the
new models and also very good discounts
and also some refurbished ones so if you
guys are looking to buy definitely go
and check that out and I hope support
our channel helps us to keep making
videos like these ones especially when
we're stuck at home being quarantined
here so you guys can see that these
machines basically look identical if I
just stack them on top of each other the
footprint is the same and if we look at
the back over here and it really looks
identical now what is different is when
we look at the front the MacBook Air has
its classic wedge shape that I
personally really like whereas the
MacBook Pro has its standard kind of
more of a boxy squarish design and then
if we look from the side over here you
guys will see that a little wedge cut
out and that makes the MacBook Air a
little bit more comfortable in the hand
to hold and makes it feel like it's kind
of thinner and smaller that was a very
smart design just design decision by
Apple when they designed the first one
whereas the MacBook Pro definitely does
feel chunkier now as far as weight
differences this one comes in at 3
pounds the MacBook Pro whereas the
MacBook Air it got slightly heavier for
2020 2.8 pounds so in all reality there
really isn't much of a difference on the
exterior now both these models also have
two Thunderbolt 3 ports that run at full
speed 40 gigabit
per second and then also a headphone
jack if you take a quick glance at the
insides you might not notice a
difference right away but the MacBook
Pro even the base model does have the
touch bar and you know some people like
them a lot of people don't like them
personally I don't use mine that often
other than the built-in commands both
these machines do have touch ID built in
which works very well and then if we
look down low where you'll see that the
MacBook Pros trackpad is slightly larger
now I have no issues with the MacBook
Airs trackpad it is plenty big enough it
doesn't limit you whatsoever so that is
not a complaint and then looking above
you might notice some differences in the
keyboard now this uses the same new
magic keyboard as Apple calls it from
the 16 inch MacBook Pro and I absolutely
love that keyboard now I wasn't a huge
hater of the butterfly keys they are
larger than the previous ones they're
more tactile they're very stable now
basically what Apple did is took this
design and then put in a scissor
mechanism with better travel so this is
the best of both worlds from Apple's old
keyboards and the butterflies combined
and what most people care about is long
term reliability and you definitely know
that you're not gonna have any issues
with this new one now I will say that
this MacBook Pro does use the latest
version of the butterfly keyboard and I
have not heard any issues with that both
of these laptops use 720p FaceTime
cameras and this is the quality from the
new 2020 MacBook Air and this is the
base 2019 MacBook Pros webcam and
microphone quality you guys go ahead and
let me know down in the comments section
below which one looks in sounds better
if you guys could tell a difference now
let's talk about the displays both of
these are high quality high resolution
retina displays we have the same exact
size the same resolution but we do have
some differences the MacBook Air gets
around 350 to maybe 400 nits of
brightness whereas the MacBook Pro can
output 500 nits and that will help out
if you're in bright rooms maybe outside
you're battling some reflectivity now
there's one other difference and that is
the color gamut the MacBook Air can do
very well for srgb so if you're doing
standard JPEG photos you want to edit
those you're gonna have a good color
accuracy but the map
Pro can actually display dcpip three
colors which means it's just more colors
that can show off you guys see this logo
right here is actually showing up
whereas on the MacBook Air that color
cannot be displayed so we're not seeing
that how big of a deal is that well I
think for most people it really doesn't
matter personally if I was doing things
like video editing and especially for
HDR where you're gonna be doing 10 bits
I would say definitely you would want
the MacBook Pros display now it's time
to compare the speakers you guys put on
your best pair of headphones and I want
you guys to listen to both and let me
know what differences you hear down in
the comments section below
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'll give you guys my opinions the
MacBook Pro does have the better
speakers it is louder the bass sounds
better and the highs are much more crisp
and sharp if you want the best speakers
definitely go for the MacBook Pro but I
will say that the MacBook Air is not a
slouch the speaker's still sound good
better than most Windows laptops that
I've tested it's gonna be interesting
comparing it to the surface laptop 3
because that has a great speaker system
and I absolutely love that Windows
laptop so make sure you guys are
subscribed with notifications enabled if
you guys want to see that comparison now
we are going to be moving on to
performance test this is gonna get very
very interesting but first let me give a
shout out to our sponsor Squarespace if
you've been thinking about making a new
website or replacing your old one now is
the time and Squarespace is the best
option even if you've had no web making
experience all you do is choose a
template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
has been running for over two years now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in SEO tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
literally anything else go to
squarespace.com slash max tech or use
our custom link below and start your
free no credit card required two-week
trial and when you're ready to launch
you will save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain and
now let's test out the SSD performance
as I mentioned this is a base model
MacBook Pro so it has 128 gig SSD at the
read performance is very similar but the
write performance the macbook air is man
almost three times faster now that is
because we do have a 128 gig if you went
out and you got a 256 gig version of the
MacBook Pro then it would be pretty much
matching up as far as SSDs and now let's
get into performance so I'm gonna go
ahead and start this Geekbench 5 test
and as it's running I'll give you guys
the specs now this MacBook Pro is the
base model has 8 gigabytes of low power
ddr3 has a 1.4 gigahertz quad core i5
processor and that goes up to 3.9
gigahertz now with this MacBook Air
because Apple dropped the prices and
they're giving us a better value I went
up to an i5 from the
three that gives us a quad-core
processor that starts at one point one
gigahertz and goes up to three point
five now I would say for almost anybody
that's buying a MacBook Air spend that
extra $100 because your performance is
going to get much better not only that
but graphics as well so it's well worth
it now the other difference is that the
MacBook Pro uses an eighth generation
Intel processor whereas this MacBook Air
is the first Mac to use a tenth
generation processor and here we have a
results and I was not expecting this now
as far as multi-core score the MacBook
Pro which has a higher frequency
processor and better cooling this gets
22% higher multi-core score which I was
expecting but what I wasn't was that the
MacBook Air would get a 26% higher
single core score this MacBook Air has a
faster and higher single core score than
my 12 core Mac Pro it is it is really
good and this means that if you're doing
simple tasks like web browsing opening
up tabs new applications it's gonna be
very snappy and now let's switch over to
the graphics I'm gonna be running the
metal test if you're getting the i5
processor you're gonna get the same
exact graphics as the i7 version ok wow
I was not expecting this big of a
difference both have iris plus graphics
this has 10 yet the MacBook Air is
basically scoring three times as high as
the MacBook Pro in metal man that that's
getting me very interested in the final
cut test but first this is Unigine
Heaven using the extreme preset and this
is gonna get interesting because it's
gonna be putting a lot of heat on the
GPU is a more consistent load and Wow
another thing that I did not expect so
for gaming when you're pushing the
graphics to the max for an extended
period of time the MacBook Pro graphics
are actually faster we've got 10 point 6
FPS compared to 9 point oh that is
interesting and then if I look at the
graphics temperatures this one the
MacBook Air is running at 81 Celsius
compared to 76 so even though the
graphics chip itself isn't getting too
hot the CPU is putting out a bunch of
heat altogether and that means it has to
slow down I think now is the perfect
time to get into thermal
Worman so first off the fans are not
being maxed out on either one of these
systems
7100 RPM spray can go all the way up to
8,000 so the fan does run faster but the
fan running faster isn't going to make a
difference because if you guys look at
these shots right here you'll see that
the MacBook Air the new one just like
the old ones the heatsink is not
connected to the actual fan so it does
draw air in and the actual cool has been
redesigned to have these little chambers
but without any heat pipes they cannot
do that good of a job cooling down I
have seen a bench r20 open here we're
just gonna put a huge load on all of the
cores with the CPU and then Intel power
gadget so we can see what's happening
with our wattage with our temperatures
and with our frequencies let's go ahead
and click start where for our multi core
test and right off the bat this hit 3.5
gigahertz compared to MacBook MacBook
Pro hitting 3.9 gigahertz and as soon as
our test starts we are down to 2.4
MacBook Air is slowing down faster it's
already hit a hundred degrees Celsius
compared to 78 the i5 10 gen in the
MacBook Air is actually a wide processor
so it's designed to be ultra efficient
low power usage and even though it did
spike up to 25 watts it didn't stay
there very long whereas this is running
right now 26-28 the CPU is running still
at 3 gigahertz and the MacBook Air
settled at 1.5 gigahertz around 1011
watts
so this is where thermal performance and
having heatsink that's actually
connected to the fan comes into plate
that means that even though the MacBook
Pro is only 22% faster and Geekbench 5s
multi-core score if you're gonna be
putting a 100% load on all of the cores
for an extended period of time because
of thermals the MacBook Pro is 65%
faster and now I'm very curious about
video editing so I have final cut open
in front of me I'm gonna do just a few
tests but if you guys want a more
detailed video on how the 2020 MacBook
Air handles video editing go ahead and
check out the link in the video
description to my other channel where
I'll do a video just on that now
starting out here I have
two Clips open side-by-side this is a 20
second 4k clip I'm gonna test out
stabilization which is going to test the
graphics performance for a video editing
I'm gonna click here hit start it's been
20 seconds and so far the MacBook Air is
ahead at 60% compared to 43 now it is
starting to heat up a bit
so should be slowing down to live as far
as graphics it got done in 35 seconds
whereas the MacBook Pro is still at 63
degrees Celsius it's not heating up at
all when we're doing this task 45
seconds so 10 seconds slower next I have
a 5-minute 4k project open the same clip
here but we have some color correction
applied I have a lot up light onto here
and some film grain so I'll let's go
ahead just hit the spacebar I have it
set up to the better quality so this is
full 4k being played back here and as
far as smoothness I mean both of them
are looking pretty good and now let's
export this five-minute 4k project with
effects I'm using the web browser preset
in 4k and after 22 seconds we're already
at 95 99 degrees Celsius where's the
MacBook Air 72
the fans are idling so yeah we're seeing
a good trend here so it's been pretty
much 5 minutes and the MacBook Pro is at
52% where this MacBook Air is at 26%
so basically if for video editing the
MacBook Pro is twice a slow once you
actually get into it and you are doing
some heavier stuff for short bursts
excellent very good but for long stuff I
mean we could see right here it's it's
literally thirty percent sixty percent
at five and a half minutes it's not
worth so I'm gonna cancel this if you
guys want to see me testing out some
1080p video editing and maybe a couple
other scenarios that video will be in
the video description but I don't want
to be sitting here waiting this much
longer so let's finish up this video
guys and which one of these would I
recommend as the best value first off
the MacBook Air definitely surprised me
the fact that the single core score was
26% higher than this one is EXO
and the multi-core score was 22% lower
not thus big of a difference that I was
expecting in that kind of regarding for
regular tasks regular productivity apps
web usage email typing that kind of
stuff this will actually be snappier
date today not only that but the battery
life is also better now Apple doesn't
give a big difference I think they read
this at 11 hours compared to 10 but in
my usage I would say for kind of medium
loads not just video playback you're
gonna get maybe two hours better I would
say at least two I mean right now just
looking at the bag of life during the
test this thing fared way better even
under load so that is excellent of
course the keyboard is excellent the
shape of the bodies great for typing so
for those people that are doing regular
tasks like simple productivity emails
web use the stuff that this machine was
designed for this is even better than
it's ever been before because it now has
way more performance for those regular
usages now unfortunately if you're gonna
be putting them under heavy load say 4k
video editing that's extended gaming it
cannot keep up because of thermals in
that situation the MacBook Pro is still
the king even though it's definitely
weaker in terms of graphics now the
display is better here it's brighter the
speaker sound better and for different
things like photo editing video editing
stuff like that you're gonna want the
better color accuracy and the much
better cooling performance so I'll have
links to both down in video description
below there are some great deals on the
MacBook Pros well that brings it closer
to the MacBook Airs price you guys can
go and check that out thank you guys for
wash and click that circle above to
subscribe and if you want to see some
other videos on the MacBook Air we'll
have them right over there the spin Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]